hands like this you know what this means
maya time i am if you don't listen to
this promo the dog goes goes bang bang
tell him maya
you're so cute
okay maya let me tell you about a great
deal nordvpn you don't browse internet
unprotected right that's cringe right i
taught you this
that's right you use nordvpn with norvpn
all your internet data stay safe behind
the wall of next-gen encryption bam
bam push it away maya
like that maya protected
they don't log anything strict no logs
policy they don't track they don't
collect
and they don't share your private data
my app
that's a good dog sorry i scared you a
little bit they have a vast selection of
400 service in 59 countries baby
worldwide mr worldwide that's right and
it's available on multiple devices use
it on your phone use it on your computer
i use it all the time and it's super
fast it's quick reliable and it's safe
and i recommend checking it out because
if you sign up for a two-year plan you
get an additional four months for free
use the link in the description to
unlock this offer
3.18 a month for a two-year plan that's
a great deal that's a steal that's
nordvpn.com
pewdiepie all right let's get along with
the video right maya
[Music]
you're so cute
15 signs you're a beta ma'am i should
get zero on this i'm pretty sure and if
you're subscribed to this channel you
should get zero too let's watch this is
the sunday motivational video
every sunday we bring you a different
type of video which should improve your
life
today we're looking at can't wait for my
life to get improved
15 signs you're a beta male
welcome to
okay let me try this
bad posture
wife has a boyfriend
subscribe to coke
not subscribe to pewdiepie
hello alexers now this sunday video will
make a couple of you guys cry because
not me living in a body so absolutely
not [ __ ] yourself right to see
reality for what it actually is what a
patronizing [ __ ] okay this town is an
unremarkable mediocre careful man who
avoids risk and confrontation
beta males lack the physical presence
charisma confident
associated with winners in life
you're probably thinking well that
doesn't sound like me no it doesn't
matter
always well-being
it's time to put that to the test we
made this video specifically for those
of you who are struggling with this
we're not talking about gym lads who can
bench press twice their body weight but
instead we're focusing on a more
holistic approach
some might even mention that there are
other categories like gamma males and
omega males but to be honest i'm
infinity male i'm above male i rise
above meta mayo honest if you've got an
alpha does it even matter what you call
yourself metamail that's good no let's
coin that right the capability to deal
with the situation directly it's enough
to go to oh my god she keeps blabbing
fifteen signs let's go number one here
are the 15 signs
she says correct what to do about it
number one you don't feel like your life
is getting better and better what the
[ __ ]
look i'm a beta god damn it
well it has to always get better
incrementally that's ridiculous that is
dumb stop it it gotta go worse to get
better sometimes stop it [ __ ] stop it
no
not dumb dumb what is number two
skipping this you never face your voice
and stick around in your adult life
most people get both you can't get
bullied unless you never get bullied
okay why would i why why i go i go back
to school just to confront them what am
i supposed to do and i was never bullied
anyway because you can't get bullied if
you don't get bullied idiots dummies
okay dumb what you never
what
stupid
i'm not a beta
this is dumb
this is
so dumb what the hell i'm sorry i didn't
grow a supernatural powers like
spider-man and started confronting
people okay what am i supposed to do my
point is the best way to deal with
bullies is to act like they don't face
you because they just want a reaction
out of you and they're taking out
whatever sort of [ __ ] they're
dealing with onto you or their
insecurities onto you
so don't just just don't engage with it
okay yeah you're welcome can't get
bullied if you don't get both you'll
have to deal with them throughout your
entire life oh my god all right what's
number three you rely on others like
your family to make decisions for you
okay
dude is everyone gonna be beta male in
history i actually don't do this at all
maybe it's a personality trait thing i i
think it has nothing to do with beta or
offer man number one sign up being a
better you let people classify you right
it seems like people always want other
people's opinion which i i don't know
i'm like bro i don't know where you're
asking me is your choice at the end of
the day i don't know all the nuances of
the different outcomes of the choices
that you are weighing what the hell do
you want me to do i don't know stop
letting other people make choices for
you although i mean i did kind of go to
university like my parents wanted me to
do so i you know what guess i was a beta
now i met a man number four
you are physically weak
no no
[Music]
you're no weak
this is so ridiculous okay if if i want
to entertain this concept of beta and
alpha male right it all comes down to
confidence to me has nothing to do with
physical
strength right nothing it's all
confidence
physical strength is often a
contributing factor in self-confidence
it happens to also be an indication of
someone's health and if you are under
the impression
that you are more of an alpha male or
some sort of cooler guy because you have
muscles and that's some dumb schmuckery
as well then you're that's some beta
that's some beta brain if you're in the
friend zone you're probably a beta male
the truth is most of you end up in the
friend zone because all you do is act
like a friend not a possible partner
you've positioned yourself incorrectly
and now you're stuck there
but alux i'm in the friend zone because
i'm too nice i'm not a douchebag
no you're probably not as nice as you
think you are just because you think of
yourself as a nice guy doesn't mean the
world should see you the same way
well no just because
she worded this completely wrong just
cause you are a nice guy doesn't mean
anyone owes you [ __ ] okay
but i was nice to girl why she no let me
peepee i'm like
just because you're a nicer person
doesn't mean that you have any
obligations whatsoever to you so it's so
entitled to imagine that right listen
listen i don't do fred i don't do
relationship advice often but if you're
into someone it's better to tell them
and if you think they're gonna say no
don't tell them and just move on okay
don't get stuck on one person
there's someone out there for you okay
you better take a chance then no chance
but you got don't linger i think that's
the problem with people and friends and
they linger stop lingering number six
you can't say no and stand your ground
males have a hard time saying no to
other people just this is a skill you
have to learn
i think i i definitely was the kind of
person that couldn't say no and then you
end up feeling miserable because you're
doing a bunch of stuff you didn't want
to do it takes confidence again to say
no so uh yeah i actually agree with this
one that's a good sign good telltale
sign some hide under the mask that again
they're just being nice or being a
people pleaser and
i don't i wouldn't like people that
can't say no to say yes either like if i
ask someone to do something and they
don't want to do it i'd much rather they
say no
anyway so it makes no sense why you
wouldn't be able to say no in my opinion
at least a different circumstances gray
areas but still even in your sucker
friends people make fun of you
number seven even in your circle of
friends some people make fun of you
it's all fun and games until you realize
that even in your circle of friends
you're one of the weakest links and your
friends treat you as such
this can happen for a multitude of
reasons bro
nah
nah disagree the strongest with this one
everyone makes fun of everyone in the
friend group
right
government pay taxes no i'm not a beta
15 out of 15. i got a perfect score i'm
using the word beta made on a writer
right this might seem arrogant and i'll
try and work this correctly but i do
feel like in the past
with friend groups i had in the past
there's been times where i feel like
everyone has had to rip into me because
they had their own insecurities about my
success on on youtube and in general so
i don't think that makes you better
ma'am i just think it's a thing that
happens
that can kind of suck i'm not a better
bear make sure to stand your ground and
earn the respect of the group do not
simply demand it because nobody has to
give you anything
don't be the friend that's left walking
alone behind the group add real value to
the squad and be treated as an equal
you can be made fun of in between us and
equals still that one no dumb so dumb
your existence largely centers around
past times like browsing the internet
anime video games oh no
there's so much distraction around us
that it's easy to get trapped into binge
watching that's a beta male [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] this is
imagine watching this game existential
crisis
your existence largely centers around
pastime what is your existence
central brand in general
i don't know this youtube channel oh god
that's depressing even that well i don't
know i think what gives my
existence centered largely largely is
around growing
learning new things that kind of stuff
without that i don't know where i'd be
but you know i mean i don't know memes
on huge lol or nine gag won't make you
smarter or a more interesting person
okay that this is you apparently the i i
agree with this unless you subscribe to
pewdiepie then uh obviously you make
excuses no i don't
i at one point you need to face the
truth you're always finding excuses when
the real reason why you're not taking
action is because you're scared of
failure or you're just lazy
sooner or later life is going to hit you
like a brick house because this kind of
behavior not only is not rewarded in the
real world but it's going to make it
even more difficult for you to deal with
the real world
number 10 you have no sense of style ah
oh like they like they have sense of
style excuse me they look [ __ ] dumb
as [ __ ]
perfect sense of style perfect couldn't
get better i got that sookie
suzuki shirt on as you can tell perfect
sense of style thank you
thank you i'm above fashion [ __ ] shut
up you don't look people in the eye and
you're nervous when you talk to them
this is normal
okay sorry i don't like staring at
people
sorry
also it's weird when people do it i'm
like dude why are you staring at me it's
weird stop all right all right imagine
this is how i would talk to someone i
know you're supposed to look above them
sometimes but then it's like why am i
thinking about these things that just
makes it so weird like i'm a robot
okay hey how you doing cool
awesome
i don't know i don't know how to talk to
people shut up shut up i'm not a beta
shut up uh you don't get laid much
even when you do it's not that great oh
much and even when you do it's not that
great
being a sexually active person is a sign
of good health
if you've checked off most of the boxes
so far it isn't a surprise that you
don't engage with the opposite sex oh no
when would you when you're spending most
of your free time playing fortnite or
binge watching oh my god this woman shut
up
that's nothing wrong
nothing wrong with not engaging other
sex okay some some of these things
behavior borderline disruptive
anyway okay don't let that not pass this
is this toxic [ __ ]
actually has a big ego but you can't
control it
i thought about this a lot because uh
swedish people it's kind of natural of
us
to
uh not have an ego as a swede
it's kind of built in we even have a
word for it like jante logan i think
it's called it's like you're not allowed
to brag love jumping
you're not you're just not allowed to
brag which i agree with like it's ugly
but i also feel like um it's it can go
the other way too where if you're
successful at something if you catch
yourself saying like
oh
you know i could have done way better or
or actually you know this or actually
like when you try and downplay your
success that can't be healthy either
right i think we're taught so much in
sweden especially that you're not
allowed to brag whatsoever that it's
just become the complete opposite where
it's not healthy either ego is just one
of those things where you have to be
honest with yourself and you're like are
you being an egomaniac or no are you
just being proud of yourself and what
you've accomplished i don't know like
you should be able to be allowed to do
it so
yeah number 14. you're a follower not a
leader uh-huh data males are not the
ones who take initiative they usually
wait for someone else to initiate and
then jump on the bandwagon
they rarely have seems smart right
as a beta i respect that decision that's
clever
right makes sense to me
people disregard his ability to achieve
results
this often happens in companies where
usually people rally behind those who
manage to get the best results yeah but
then now all the pressure is on them if
it goes wrong you know they're the ones
taking the fall for it with that you
feel a fit if you're offended by this
video you're a beta [ __ ]
no i'm criticizing your video because
it's dumb
make this video to offend anybody
instead consider it more like a cold
shower which would make everyone reflect
on what their life is currently like and
maybe find a few ways to improve
if you take a single piece of
information from this video tackle it
head on and your life is better because
of it that we're pleased with the end
result there are two types of this is
the worst video i've probably seen in a
while i
like i understand it's purpose and i
can't disagree with all of it but i i
mean come on dude if you actually think
these things matter that's some real
better
like this has to yeah this has to be a
joke right
oh signs you're an alpha male okay let's
do it i just want to see you really
quick you're really happy with your life
okay sure you feel controller of your
life sure three is so quick you don't
get see you get things done yeah
whatever oh man all right well now we
found out hope we learned something
today be uh be yourself and be confident
with yourself and that's all that really
matters right that's how i feel anyway
thanks for watching brofist you thought
it was gay
but true relevance never really died
welcome to the first undead game use any
item in your inventory and make memes
inside tuber simulator add some of our
patented stickers in there stickers our
emotions memes our emotions express your
emotions with me
show them for likes share them for love
get up for free
and who knows
maybe i'll review your memes the
greatest honor of all time full circle
baby download it make a meme
we need subtitles on this